[Music]
who here likes
titty milk anybody can't say did you
taste uh jill's titties [ __ ] up so bad
what do you mean how did you fail where
is this going well like i uh he's so
just we all had a fat he's so distracted
one of us have a titty milk
access
[Laughter]
we will taste it wait
and then talk about it because i was so
curious right about what titty milk was
gonna taste like and i was so curious
and i couldn't wait she's gonna get
pregnant hell yeah and then the minute
she became pregnant you kind of go into
like this dad mode
and i forgot that i had unanswered
questions that need answers
and i never filled in the blank did you
feel like you were stealing taika's food
no you're just i'm not even i'm just not
leaving
the the the whole thing about trying the
titty milk didn't even cross my mind
during that period it's okay i think if
you guys want to try uh titty milk it
probably tastes like barbell horchata
like this
exactly delicious exactly that's what it
was designed i would assume it's like
that i know a buddy who um they were
playing drinking games you know what i
mean and then whoever would like lose a
game would have to take a shot of breast
milk that was in the fridge wait where
did that come from it was just in the
fridge
from a lactating mother at the time
wouldn't the baby need that like what
we're just yeah but i need one
what did they say it tasted like that
tastes good it was kind of sweet i don't
know if they were judging it when they
were drunk and using it as punishment as
like tastes good but i i didn't also
inquire about the details i should have
shucks
are you curious about it or not uh i'm
getting more curious now that i see your
conviction i didn't realize that you had
missed a huge opportunity
it's contagious now i'm like i want to
know
i'm curious i just don't want to know
the girl but i hope that she's organic
and free range
free range girl
be your girls titty milk oh that'll be
the best free range means that as long
as she has like a hundred you know
square feet of walking around
that's the conspiracy right it's like
they're in a warehouse all day it's free
range but they don't really get sun yeah
that's true that's a [ __ ] travis so
this is mom
on only fans again who makes over 10 000
pounds a month wow selling breast milk
videos wow oh just videos that's
thirteen thousand six hundred sixty
dollars a month selling videos of spray
expressing or like the pump oh
well the thing is what how many ways can
you get and extract breast milk and what
can you do with it right you got to get
creative with these content
so
this mom has paid off her debts and
pulls in over 13 000 months selling
videos of herself you know showing
breast milk and and getting it out her
name is alice lovegood just in case
you want to find me i don't though i do
everybody writing it down she has three
children
was around 20 000 in debt when she came
up with the idea of selling her videos
and has since cleared what she owes
and earns a huge amount of money a month
i like where people pay off debt yeah
that makes me you know that's a that's a
full-on um
pissed
only fans ruining the money bank is like
no no what would you pay guys come on
oh she's hot
oh she's oh she's oh that's what she's
doing those are the pumps
i thought there was two angel ornaments
on her boobs
how come it's pixelated right there
because you can see the nipple probably
is that why i think at the top or is
that a halter top colored in oh it's a
it's a top oh okay yeah
oh interesting okay you know you know at
um on the liquor store my roommate aunt
so like um
in the back of his liquor store he had a
a naughty section right with a curtain
and all that
18 plus
and then um he said like some of the
perverts are so [ __ ] bold that they
have they're just shameless about like
their kinks right and then a dude would
be like hey uh
do you have any do you have any things
with milk and he goes milk he goes yeah
you know like
like when the woman is like spraying the
milk in the guy's mouth or something
like that
he's like
i don't even know where to get that and
they're like you don't and he would get
it yeah serves him right like the
customers would escalate yeah would get
mad as if he's like he's like how can
you not have cherry [ __ ] slurpee like
you have blueberry why could you just
get cherry yeah i'm with him on that i'm
with him on that if you're gonna have a
whole section have a low variety yeah he
had a dude that was outraged because he
didn't have breast milk porn well i
guess i could understand if he was
outraged if like he didn't have breast
milk porn but he had like a myriad of
other [ __ ] up weird kings and fetishes
you know what i mean like i get why
people do that though is because at that
moment he looks weird so he wants the
other dude delusional
yeah
it's like oh [ __ ]
this place sucks speaking extra loud
because there's random customers walking
around
check this guy out doesn't have
lactation porn in his store
[Laughter]
one of her followers actually even
offered her up to over a hundred
thousand pounds to for her to breastfeed
him
but she turned down the offer because
you know just content how she doesn't
like money much
because someone doesn't like money to
where they could just throw a hundred
grand or do you think this is something
they saved up and they're like i was
gonna down pay a house
no way dude no
they gotta be for real for real rich but
they just can't cross that line with
like their own ecosystem or some [ __ ]
like that so they need like somebody
else who already facilitates that type
of space yeah for them to see if they
can cross that bridge it's like jeff
bezel's uh right hand man or something
amazon
or just some like tech giant in china or
some [ __ ]
milk dudes does it turn you on no um it
turns on my science brain for me i
haven't gone there yet
maybe it's because i haven't had a child
yet so i haven't had a woman who had to
go through that that i even i'm in close
proximity to understand that yeah you
know what i mean i see it from friends
but you never i'm never going to be like
hmm i should think about tooty milk as i
said like my friend yeah that's like my
child i see that as like parenthood it's
too maternal it's not it's not a sexy
time i see it as culinary arts
so it's difficult to mix food and sex
for me it's like a cooking show when you
say yeah it's like a cookie you know
it's like kitchen i saw one
irvine i saw breast milk porn like they
would [ __ ] and then later like she would
[ __ ] like like the way that guy is
[ __ ] on her face like she was [ __ ]
[ __ ] in a guy's face with her boob
right yeah and then i don't know i was
probably too young to watch this because
i never seen a booby express milk before
and i was like
the first thing that came to mind was
that [ __ ] is a broken sprinkler yeah or
like a or like a shower head that has
too much [ __ ] hard water corrosion
and you gotta rub the [ __ ] to make it
spray better yeah that's what it looks
there's a it looks like there's a
blockage yeah nature is [ __ ] up man
why can't they just make it a nice clean
shower head so the baby has a good
stream maybe it fills the mouth better
like oh
yeah but it's all like this or if it
leaks otherwise i'll just feel like a
leaking system but on that like i have
tried it before oh lucky bro
say say that earlier
at two minutes i was trying to
but what it was was uh
my mom my mom had my my mom got pregnant
with my sister when we were already like
twelve right somebody was like
no no but she had like you know she
would do the pumps in case like you know
we were going out and stuff like that
and it was in the fridge once and we all
were just like [ __ ] let's try it real
quick so we took a little sip but it
didn't really like taste like weird or
did it taste like just regular milk oh
not not really regular milk it was to me
from what i remember wasn't really like
tasteful was it sweeter was it
was it like goat milk hazelnuts
and [ __ ] [ __ ] but also though you
know when like you drink like um uh tap
water and you know it's tap water when
it's lukewarm but when you put in the
fridge because it's cold it's like
easier to say also oh
oh
our drinks were like this
yeah i want to know the difference
between like from the body body
temperature oh thank you you gotta give
it one of these aerate it versus like
refrigerated it just it looks a little
different it looks like almost like
from what i mean yeah yellow yeah so
like we were kind of we thought it was
gonna be all weird but it was like
it wasn't really that well it's like
sperm you know sometimes you think sperm
is just gonna be clear or white but it's
like yellowish you're like that's cause
you're clogged up you haven't had it
come out in a long time what are you
talking about large quantities yeah it
does look yellow yeah you still got
covered have you have you seen um
there's this girl that posted uh
covered breast milk
and then regular breast milk and she put
it side by side and the covered breast
milk was green whoa that's crazy i'm
gonna google covered breast milk yeah it
is insane
yeah and then it was like this is my
regular it's like straight green yeah it
had wheatgrass it looked like green eggs
and ham spirulina
oh man i needed if i should have just
when i had kovitz just double checked
see if it was green right here nobody
wants to see that
he's like guys i did an experiment while
i was sick
i know you've been waiting for like
matcha
it's matcha disney dude
am
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] man that's [ __ ]
coveted breast milk dog
that's white people guacamole right
there
they blended it yeah
guacamelee or something
that's what caused it
i did eat guacamole every day oh that's
what it was it wasn't the coconut yeah
dang that
yeah it's great it turns green i wonder
if you could change the flavor profile
with your diet through your breasts yeah
you can turn it into mango and go go
see that's what i'm talking about all of
the jamba juice all week
so uh this lady who alice is her name 27
she said before i started doing this
last year our life was very different we
were in over you know 20 000 debt and i
worked all the time including weekends
and we had never been on a family
holiday
now i can put my kids into good school
if i choose to and i can spend quality
time with them i know some people think
posting videos of my breast milk is
disgusting but it's natural and i don't
care what people say i'm proud of what
i've achieved and i love the confidence
it's given me what happens like when
like she's not pregnant and stuff though
she loses her job when she's not lying
she better cash in as much as she can
yeah i heard like if they keep getting
stimulated or whatever you could you'll
keep lactating yourself oh really yeah
really cause what are they called wet
nurses or whatever they don't even have
kids oh did you start that's right yeah
yeah actually
a leftover meal that's crazy
guys i never realized how interesting
breast milk and breastfeeding is it is
kind of interesting it's food yeah it's
crazy how it works because you don't
think about this [ __ ] you know yeah you
bring it to my attention now i'm
thinking about it we don't carry food in
our body that's what i mean men can't do
that i know we only have a little bit of
food that comes out
what's like the calories on it you think
per you know
80 samples 80
[Laughter]
that's good for everything
[Music]
[Music]
you